[Music]
welcome to the Macmillan report I'm
Marilyn Wilkes your host and our guest
is Alexander guy ovitch Syed a
postdoctoral fellow at the Macmillan
Centre and a lecturer in the Department
of Political Science at Yale University
professor guy ovitch Sai egg is
particularly interested in climate
justice and its relation to climate
policy as well as in the ethics of
carbon pricing today we'll talk with
professor guy ovitch Tsai egg about his
research on climate justice after the
Paris agreement welcome thank you for
having me let's start with an overview
of the paper that you have forthcoming
in the Journal of global ethics tell us
about it
sure this paper presents another way to
respond to the question of how the
burdens to mitigate climate change so to
reduce our carbon emissions should be
divided between countries think of the
question should developing countries be
allowed to pollute the way this question
is framed suggests that the for us to
give developing countries less
responsibilities is to allow them to
pollute more my paper wants for us to
resist the temptation of answering the
question in this way and I argued that
the principles of climate justice we
have should not be applied to emissions
reductions but should be applied to
climate finance which I will explain in
a moment essentially what this paper
tries to accomplish is to find a way a
strategy for us to develop in a clean
way allowing developing countries to
develop in a clean way and still reduce
our carbon emissions so I try to provide
the principles of justice that should
regulate climate finance and I try to
apply this to the Green Climate Fund and
what why I write the paper what can what
what inspired you to write the paper
well two things first that I believe
facts have changed on the ground
developing countries are now the
much more than it used to developing
countries are today responsible for 63%
of global emissions where they only were
responsible to 41% back in 2004 just to
give a comparison so the way for us to
include these countries in a meaningful
way to reduce their carbon emissions and
be fair sounded like an interesting
question for someone working on climate
justice and secondly while I was writing
the paper I realized that developing
countries were still urging rich
countries to fulfill their pledges of
climate finance which are essentially
today to have a hundred billion dollars
available annually since from 2022 for
developing countries to mitigate and to
adapt to climate change okay now did
these developing countries participate
in the Paris agreement did they sign off
on that they absolutely all of them did
so with that said how are they moving
what are some of the developing
countries who are the larger produced
producer of emissions so some of them
are what we call the basic countries so
Brazil South Africa India China they are
amount they are among the biggest
polluters today Indonesia too is among
among these countries who produce who
have large populations and and pollute a
lot so the thing is that they have
somewhat decrees they have fought
poverty and at the same time have
increased their emissions so if this
should be a model to all countries to
try to fight poverty we would have a
problem right right
so how did you do the research for the
paper what was your methodology well
essentially I did one of the things I
liked I enjoyed the most which are
trying to model principles of justice in
the real world so there was a little bit
of a challenge here it was just not to
formulate principles of climate justice
but you see how they can be applied in
the real world and also I found that the
the leading principle we had since the
real summit in 1992 which is the
principle of common but differentiated
responsibilities was a little bit
imprecise I think we needed to
define more clearly what we mean by this
principle this which is why I suggested
that we break down this notion and say
that we have common responsibilities to
mitigate but differentiated
responsibilities finance so we all have
to reduce our carbon emissions but will
not all pay the same right and let's go
into detail with that talk a little bit
more about that and give us some
specifics so I think that the
traditional way that we approach this
question to say that you know for to
have differentiated responsibilities to
reduce carbon emissions is a strategy
design it's no longer available today so
it seems to me that for us to include
all countries and still do that in a way
that is fair we needed a new mechanism
and the notion of climate finance have
tried to respond have that to respond to
this and my paper is aims to find a more
structure way and a more just way to do
that
ok and what would be a more just way to
do that so I think it's important that
we try to model these principles of
climate justice really take into account
the developments in kind of governance
so what happened after Paris and really
take into account the real state of
carbon emissions today for me a just way
to do that would be to use our best
principles of climate justice the best
principles are kind of justice in my
opinion are the principles of capacity
and the principle of historical
responsibility these two principles mean
capacity that we don't have the same
capacity to find climate change the
principle says that capacity should be
assigned the responsibility should be
assigned according to agents capacity to
respond to the problem so we don't have
all have the same capacity to specify
climate change and developed countries
have the capacity to help developing
countries do that and the principle
historical responsibility says that his
responsibilities should be assigned
according to agents historical
connection to the problem hence the idea
that we have not all polluted the same
we have polluted much more than a lot of
developing countries therefore we have a
duty to assist them to transition to a
low-carbon economy
essentially the I think there's an
important notion in historical
responsibility that says that we have
denied them the opportunity to develop
in a way that I can't afford and this is
I think what motivates and what is
behind the idea of climate finance this
should regulate the idea of climate
finance okay how have we denied them the
opportunity to develop well we have
emitted so much in so so much in the
past that today for us to stay under two
degrees Celsius which is paramount that
we do there is no room for them to
develop in a way that in the same way
that we did so we we already at over 400
parts per million of carbon of carbon
dioxide in the atmosphere of greenhouse
gases in the atmosphere if we reached
450 that would give us a very so a very
small chance of staying under two
degrees Celsius and the way we are
we're meeting we are increasing the
concentration all about three parts per
million per year that give us very
little room and that means that is
impossible for all develop all
developing countries to develop in the
same way that we did so now we all have
to reduce our emissions which is tough
so what is the Green Climate Fund and
how does that relate to your work well
so the Green Climate Fund is a new fund
that was created to help develop
countries developing countries mitigate
so reduce their emissions and adapt to
climate change and the the Green Climate
Fund is counting a little bit on the the
the pledges of developed countries to
give a hundred billion dollars annually
so the green company would be
responsible to manage and distribute
part of this of these funds and it
relates to my research in various ways I
think two important ways is that the
Green Climate Fund is a signal and
climate finance is a signal there both
are signals to tell developing countries
they have a way to develop they have the
means develop in a low-carbon way so
this and that solar
those kinds of batteries well absolutely
also it also connects to adaptation too
but it has to do with real with
renewable energy such as wind and solar
power which are very very important okay
and who is overseeing how these
developing countries are developing and
hopefully adapting to the Paris
agreement so that's another important
way of how the Green Climate Fund
connects to my research I think the fun
is right this moment at a time that
requires a more structured way to
replenish its resources so we need a
more structure and just way to say how
we gonna raise this 100 billion per year
so that's why I think that my two
principles of justice come in and say
this actually gives us a lot of insight
or how to raise this money and it that
the Green Climate Fund today is supposed
to build trust so it is time for us to
give the Green Climate Fund the means to
fulfill its mission and we have the
means to do that
so do you foresee the United States
actually participating and giving the
appropriate amount of money to the Green
Fund well we're very far of the mark I
think especially with the recent changes
in Washington but I think there is a way
especially if we think of climate
policies like carbon pricing there are
ways for us to raise this money and
contribute to the just
amount the United States have to
participate especially given the two
reasons that we said we're the the
world's greatest economy and also we the
ones that are more responsible for for
the historical pollution so these two
reasons say that United States should be
actually the front-runner in contribute
to climate violence right unfortunately
however given the current political
situation I doubt that that's going to
happen so given that do you think that
we are significantly in danger of not
meeting that 2% cap on temperature well
so the the we we are
dangerously right now on the path of not
meeting the two degrees Celsius of
temperature increase the way things are
going right now tell us that there are
chances of us not meeting this girl I
think it's important there Paris
agreement give us a strategy for us to
increase and to ratchet up our
objectives every five years so we have
to understand that a we we are going to
scale up our our targets and so right
now we're not in the way to meet this
target but scaling up our objectives
maybe he's gonna put us on a path we're
just not right now and I think we need
the United States to be on this path
right now but perhaps with you know
recent elections maybe in four years
we've gotta be in a better but in three
years we're gonna be in a better
position than we are right now
hopefully that is a case so is the Green
Fund working directly with developing
countries and giving them funding and
kind of sharing some ideas with them as
how to you know best practices for
energy conservation oh yes well there's
a lot of research putting the Green
Climate Fund so yes they they're doing a
very good job right now I think the the
the projects that have received funds a
lot of them are going to allow
developing countries to the vet to
develop in a Korean in a green way and
also to adapt to climate change so this
has this has the potential but we really
need a know make sure that what they're
doing is transparent and you know that
we're going to have a good oversight and
also that they're gonna have the means
so I think it's an institution that
could play a large role today in the
fight against climate change okay you
also mentioned carbon pricing and I know
that's another project you're working on
- so why don't you tell us a little bit
about what you're working on in terms of
that
well this so this is well this is
another paper that is coming in right
now and so just to mention on the effort
in the United States to fight climate
change
there was a conservative plan to fight
climate change that was published early
on this year and the concern by really
prominent conservative thinkers in the
country and this plan put forward the
idea of putting a price on carbon so
there could be a bipartisan effort there
to put a price on carbon in which which
think is something that a lot of people
agree once so agree on in my opinion I
think it's where I diverge perhaps with
some of the Conservatives is that I
think this is just one measure for us to
fight climate change it's not the only
measure it's perhaps the main one but
it's not the only one so we need to put
a price on carbon right now we also need
other things but I think what is
fascinating with putting a price on
carbon is that is a way that allow us to
connect those that cause the harm with
those being harmed so we put a price on
carbon we generate funds and we could
use these funds to compensate people
that are being harmed today by climate
change and I gotta be in harm harm in
the future by climate change so I think
if we connect these two ideas while
carbon pricing should be used as a - for
climate justice and the Congressional
Budget Office just put forward a figure
that in 2011 for 2012 there with a price
a carbon price of $20 per ton of carbon
which is low it's not I think even the
Conservatives I agree that we could have
a higher price than that but even with a
low price on carbon of $20 per ton of
co2 that would give us on average a
hundred and fifteen billion per year and
in my calculations the United States who
have to pay it to be fair so the the the
the way I model the two principles of
justice of capacity and of historical
responsibility so I gave equal weight
for each one of these principles so 50
billion for the principle of capacity
and 50 billion for principle of
historical responsibility so I took the
emissions from each country starting in
1990 I calculate the United States have
to pay around 8 billion when it comes to
the principle of historical
responsibility and I calculate the
principle of capacity using both GDP per
capita and total GDP and I came out with
a figure that from the 50 billion United
States would be responsible for 21
billion dollars the biggest kind of all
the big the world's biggest Commons
economies will have to pay a substantial
amount there so I came up with a figure
that just amount the United States will
have to pay to climate justice would be
around 29 to 30 billion dollars
per year and with a carbon prodigious a
single price on carbon of $20 per ton of
carbon would be more than sufficient
would be actually three times over at
the amount that United States have to
pay for kind of justice who how do you
determine again the cost of the carbon
emission and historically how do you how
to someone track that all the the
measurement so we have improved a lot in
the measurements but that is climate
science and climate ethics and climate
policy so I wouldn't venture too much
but I know that we have on we have ways
we have monitored the emissions from
countries since 1850 quite so we have a
good notion of historical emissions from
for all countries since around like 1850
I think most people use 1990 as the sign
days to calculate historical emissions
but we have a good good precise notion
of how much countries have admitted that
because I would say if you went back to
the Industrial Age in this country I'm
sure with coal being used it would be
quite well right huge the more we go
back the more we're gonna put strong
requirements on developed countries so
if you go beer for 1990 I think we're
gonna see that the responsibilities of
developed countries are more than if we
start counting in 1990 but since that is
it since the principle I'm using of
historical responsibilities is
connection is connected to the notion of
harm that's a strong notion and we
normally you would have to give
countries at least the the notion that
they are they know that they are harming
and it's easier to tell countries that
we know that you knew that you were
harming after 1990 alright thank you so
much for being here today your work is
very important thank you very much okay
for more information about professor guy
ovitch sai egg and his work please visit
our website at McMillan report yet edu
be sure to join us again for another
episode of the McMillan report made
possible through funding from the
Whitney and Betty McMillan Center for
International and area studies at Yale
you